у цих ніби космічних капсулах дозрівають
українські діаманти їх носять світові
зірки втім про них майже не знають у
самій Україні це один з наших цехів де
Ми вирощуємо діаманти тут стоять
найбільші кубічні приси в світі
а ми тут намагаємося виростити
максимальні по розміру камені висока
температура та високий тиск те Без чого
неможливо виростити діаманти на заводі
відтворюють при ні умови росту нам
потрібна температура близько 15сяградусв
це десь дуже близько як температура біля
поверхні сонця і дуже високий тиск
приблизно як 640 африканських слонів які
вам давлять на мізинець у таких умовах
діаманти ростуть близько місяця після
чого роз'їжджаються по всій планеті
лабораторні діаманти в Україні почали
вирощувати у у 2015 році саме тоді на
базі Київського ювелірного заводу
ізумруд запрацював стартап який не
обіцяв Ані популярності Ані шалених
прибутків Утім дорогоцінне каміння
українського виробництва швидко
вподобали у Сполучених Штатах завод до
війни виробляв десь порядка 10 000 карат
на місяць Тобто це досить великі об'єми
і 100 цих діамантів йшли на експорт ми
працювали на той час в більшій частині з
Америкою з американсько ринком також з
Європейським але напевно в меншій мірі
оскільки
Європа така досить консервативна і там
ще не настільки поширені вирощені
діаманти напередодні повномасштабного
вторгнення Росією в Україну справи
компанії йшли вгору тоді одразу кілька
творінь алкорді потрапили до Книги
рекордів Гіннеса як найбільші вирощені
діаманти на 109 та 150 каратів Утім
після нападу РФ почалися проблеми з логі
адже небо над Україною закрили а згодом
додалися труднощі на виробництві через
відключення світла були кейси коли ми
просто втрачали повністю всі партії які
були під ростом через якісь відключення
світла або включалися генератори але
інколи відключення були настільки
довгими що не вистачало генераторів і
було особливо якось сумно Коли нам не
вистачило буквально тьох хвилин між
виключенням генератора і включенням
світла і за ці декілька хвилин повністю
вся партія була зміщена та компанії все
ж вдалося вийти на довоєнні об'єми
виробництва крім того з'явилися й нові
клієнти окрім того що ми відкрили
представництво безпосередньо в Америці
ми розширили географію наших продажів
тепер ми дуже багато співпрацюємо з
австралією новою зеландію також з
Великобританію і японією вироблені у
лабораторіях діаманти конкурують з
натуральними є вдвічі дешевшими і
поступово завойовують ринок крім того
вони вважаються етичним камінням адже
ростуть без руйнування шарів землі та
експлуатації праці Вони абсолютно
ідентичні за своїми хіміко-фізичними
властивостями до добутого
каміння мають туж міцність туж гру
світла абсолютно все лише інше
походження воно вирощене людиною а не
видобути з землі тож популярність
лабораторних д викликає побоювання в
Росії Яка є лідером видобутку природних
алмазів і прагне зберегти їхнє
домінування втім нині найголовніша
загроза для російського коштовного
каміння не лабораторії а 12й пакет
санкцій роботу над яким завершують в ЄС
як повідомив очільник європейської
дипломатії жозеп борель обмеження
стосуватимуться і російських діамантів з
1 грудня Вони збираються повністю
заблокувати ввезення російських алмазів
на території Європейського
союзу а уже поступово в подальшому також
буде заборона на ввезення оброблених
російських алмазів третіми країнами і це
вкрай важливо адже за словами експертів
треті країни а особливо Індія відіграють
ключову роль в обході РФ вже існуючих
діамантових санкцій країна походження
для них
цих цього виробу це вже йде країна
обробки а не країна постачальник Ну і це
ми розуміємо тобто Да дуже легкий шлях
для обходу санкцій тобто Російська
Федерація просто постачається в Індію
Індія продає без без санкцій на ринки
також обходити існуючі обмеження Росії
довгий час допомагає поширене поняття
змішані алмази умовно кажучи якщо у вас
буть
там 100 алмазів і з них 99 алмазів з
Російської Федерації один алмаз з
південноафриканської республіки то це
все буде йти згідно регуляції оцієї
алмазної галузі як алмази змішаного
походження і такі алмази не не
підпадають під під санкції очікується Що
саме 12-й пакет обмежень перекриє для
Росії ці лазівки якщо РФ дискваліфікують
з діамантової гри першим відчутним
наслідком для світового діамантового
ринку буде зростання цін а далі
поступове заміщення при природних
діамантів на лабораторні це буде
стимулювати розвиток так званих
лабораторних діамантів і вони по
поступово
поступово стають більш
конкурентноспособними на На ринку так
вони дешевші в
виробництві є відмінності Які там можуть
експерти все-таки відрізняти але з точки
зору знову ж таки ювелірної галузі то
вона напевно не так критично і це теж що
вплине тобто буде виходити заміщення за
рахунок оцих ну назвемо це штучних
діамантів наразі сегмент вирощених
діамантів займає Близько 9% від
загального ринку втім експерти очікують
на зростання частки до 25% Протягом
наступних пти років і санкції проти РФ
лише прискорять цей процес тож за таких
умов українських діамантів у світі
ставатиме більше Київський завод має
амбітні плани нарощування виробни і
виходу на ринки нових країн Чого не
скажеш про перспективи російських
лабораторних діамантів Росія теж
намагалася брати участь в цих перегонах
але Наразі я знаю декілька заводів які
вирощують але здається не так добре
йдуть в них справи діамантовий ринок він
як я кажу досить вузький да всі один
одного знають і він бесь побудований на
особистих відносинах так тому навіть ці
компанії російські які намагаються зараз
вийти зновутаки на ринок їм всі
відмовляють і гемологічні інститути і
там інші компанії крім того діамантові
санкції нанесуть відчутний удар по
економіці Росії запевняє член
міжнародної експертної групи з санкцій
Олександр Лисенко адже щороку на
діамантах які у світі вже прозвали
кривавими країна-агресорка заробляє
мільярди доларів алмазна промисловість
3,8 млрд це великі гроші це великі гроші
і це 100%
за рахунок цих грошей Російська
Федерація так само спонсорує війну в
Україні це і такий собі
дипломатично-політичний зв'язок
е Російської Федерації з де з деякими
країнами зокрема Індія Ізраїль А
це там товарообі от алмази становлять
одним із ключових елементів товарообігу
між цими країнами і Ну ми би дуже хотіли
бачити умовно кажучи ці країни ее
союзниками України і а тому
тому для нас вигідно зробити менше
скажемо менш
цікавими для цих країн співробітництво з
Росією От наприклад якщо вони не зможуть
з ними торгувати по одним із своїх
ключових елементів вони однозначно
стануть для них менш цікавими натомість
для українського коштовного каміння
відкриті всі дороги уже є навіть так
звані амбасадори українських діамантів
серед світових зірок отаку в нас брала
токольоровий
Ріана Це та що ми зробили з таким
нестандартним B resin матеріалом і
інкрустували
діамантомстандартний матеріал не
золото шлейфом в
пол